yeah man it was not my finest hour but I
got rekt by Amazon this interview
actually happened a while ago when I was
just first starting out to interview for
all these Bank companies oh and when I
mean Fang I mean Thank You Todd and I'm
not gonna say Fang Gujrat all the time
so I'm just gonna say thang so when I
say Fang think of big tech companies
anyways yeah so I got an on-site
interview I went there and then I bombed
it Amazon by the way thank you so much
audible for a spot now I'm just kidding
man but but I do want you to watch this
trailer of my startup series check it
out so I got this vision can you talk to
me a little bit more about that like
what is your startup idea yeah it's uh I
present to you not Viacom a platform to
share six point one second long looping
videos it's a website that you can
upload videos and it's a mole
what do you think about this are that
pretty dumb to be honest an account
waste time thinking about scalability on
an MVP right now our most limited
resource is my patient support shitty
idea I am the most qualified person for
themself I get [ __ ] done no we can't
launch that looks exactly like this but
to be honest I just can't get are you
off my mind whose are you
I [ __ ] hate that guy
yo-yo ma so you still working for
Microsoft so what about you were you
just so bad I doubt that I'll make him
feel the pain I felt
until it's completely broken
all right back to the Amazon interview I
just want to tell you guys quickly
play-by-play what exactly happened
because it might be useful for you guys
who want to apply to Amazon so I got an
Amazon referral from one of my friends
and yeah that's actually basically how I
applied to jobs nowadays so that I could
skip the line using the referral so yeah
make sure you make friends in college
because it's really important after a
day or two
I got a coding assessment it was a -
quoting question challenge and they give
you 90 minutes to do it
and I had to sign some sort of a
confidential agreement so I can't really
share you the questions but I could kind
of tell you it's basically easy /medium
questions and yeah that's it there's
also a section that is like describe
your approach where you just write about
how you did your question and what was
your approach and then there's also a
section that's kind of like behavioural
well I mean they call it a survey but I
think it's actually just a behavioural
portion so of course I passed it because
I've seen the questions already looking
I'm kidding
Am I I don't know I'm kidding Am I I
don't know no I'm good I didn't say
after I passed the coding assessment I
actually didn't get a phone interview I
just talked to the recruiter and they
sent me right away for an on-site which
is kind of interesting yeah so on to the
on-site here is how I [ __ ] up
immediately I went to the Amazon office
in San Francisco and I went there pretty
early I think I went there maybe 10
minutes early now you really want to go
there early because it's an interview
you don't want to be late so it's pretty
important and also you might want to
drink some water go to the bathroom
right beforehand so that's pretty
important so then I went to the lobby
and I checked in and then I asked for
the person that needs to come down to
get me I just sat in the lobby waiting
and waiting and waiting
and then because I was paranoid a two
minutes before the scheduled time
interview I checked my phone and then I
realized I asked the wrong person to
come to the front desk it's okay it's
okay I fixed it I went back to the front
desk and I fixed a no biggie no problem
I would sat back down five minutes go by
ten minutes go by and still no one was
picking me up I thought they were just
late or something so I checked my phone
and I was like [ __ ] I was in the wrong
building
so I sprinted to the right building and
I was already 15 minutes late by then
and then it took another five minutes to
get the first interviewer and when he
came he asked me you just you just flew
here this morning nope ah so so you flew
in yesterday you know traffic is pretty
bad right I mean SF is crazy
no traffic was fine did did we put you
in a hotel that was really far or
something no I actually live here you're
like in the Bay Area yeah and he just
stared at me
he was trying to hide his disappointment
and then I just said yeah I was in the
wrong building I got kind of confused
sorry so we went into the interview room
and he sat me down and he started asking
me about my resume he started asking me
about you know why I wanted to switch
back into Swee and when I was done
explaining he was like okay let me talk
about myself a little bit here's what I
do at Amazon I was like holy [ __ ] bro
dude I don't have time man I'm already
15 minutes late just give me the coding
question I mean I didn't actually say
that but that's what I was thinking like
on the exterior I was more like Oh
fascinating
mmm that is quite a difficult problem
how does your team tackle this anyways
he took his sweet-ass time and I ended
up only getting like 20 minutes for the
actual coding interview I mean I did
okay I got the optimal solution I was
able to code it up but my code had about
some bug's here and there and I was able
to fix it while I was debugging my code
but you know
I was kind of messy I didn't explain my
thought process very well because I was
I was pretty stressed with time right so
I wasn't able to perform like I would
have if I had more time to be honest
though I'm not a hundred percent sure
that is the reason why they failed me it
could be the other interviews too or
specifically one other one I'll talk
about that later anyway so then I had
four more of those interviews because in
total they have five interviews usually
it's for coding and one system design
well at least that's what I had so yeah
it's a long-ass day and you get tired by
the end of the day the four coding
questions were mostly easy to medium ly
code questions so those weren't that bad
I did decently on them because I
practice li code and I wouldn't say I
aced them but I did solve most of the
questions optimally but sometimes I
needed hints and also sometimes my code
had some bugs in there like maybe even
typos
so it wasn't flawless also each of these
interviews they actually have a
behavioral portion the thing about
Amazon is that they have something
called the 14 leadership principles and
basically what you have to do you just
have to memorize all of it and then when
they ask you behavioral questions you
have to exhibit these principles exhibit
these leadership principles so think
about your past experiences or or just
make it up whatever I don't care and but
they have to demonstrate those
leadership principles I think I did okay
because of my silver tongue or I
actually more like bronze tongue maybe
like copper copper tongue you know what
never mind
I don't think I did that well in the
behavioral portion
I can't even say behavioral and then I
also had one system design interview and
I think that's the interview that I got
screwed on because I didn't practice
system interviews that much so I think
that's why I failed so I just wanted to
share this story with you guys because I
want you to know that interviewing can
be a game of luck I mean I felt for
valid reasons but there are many times
that you
we'll fill an interview and you're gonna
feel like [ __ ] I mean I felt like [ __ ]
but it might have just been luck because
a few months later I'd say that I got
offers from companies that I wanted to
work for even more so you never know I
mean sometimes it's just a numbers game
it's pretty random I want to end this
video on this no your interview
performance says nothing about you it
says nothing about your worth it says
nothing about your intelligence and it
says nothing about how good of a
software engineer you are heck I got a
few good offers from these big tech
companies but I don't think I'm that
great of a software engineer I'm just
good at interviewing it doesn't mean
anything I'm sure many of you are better
software engineers than I am but it's
just that these interviews can really
bring you down and make you lose
confidence man don't lose confidence in
yourself especially because of an
interview keep practicing keep getting
better you won't see huge differences
overnight getting these three offers
it's it's a marathon it's not a sprint
not gonna lie when I got that rejection
I was pretty depressed
I thought I told myself if I can't even
get this offer how am I gonna get the
other job offers that I want how am I
gonna switch from data science to sweet
it feels bad at first and it feels like
it's gonna be forever but it's not in
hindsight
I realized how silly it was for me to
think these things because now I got I
got my dream job I'm doing great at it
and I feel confident and I like I love
my teammates it's great sometimes
failures can be blessings in disguise so
don't dwell on your failures but use
them to grow alright so that's it and
yeah don't forget to check out daily
interview procom we send you one coding
question per day so you can keep
practicing and keep yourself accountable
when I was studying for all these
interviews I made sure that I did at
least one question a day so that's
pretty important it's a marathon it's
not a sprint
but that's it who's